so what I'm going to do is play a little
game of this or that with you and I'm
going to give you some other popular
action franchises and you're going to
have to choose between the film's
soundtrack for Geng or Twilight oh
that's a hard I'm gonna have to go with
Twilight on that one I mean you like
those I like both of them and I'd love
that look the book is better for the
Terminator or Terminator 2 oh that's a
good one cuz terminators too good but I
mean it's so hard to outdo the very
first one in the franchise I'm gonna
have to go with sunlight or two on that
I really like talking to Captain America
Winter Soldier or guardians of the
galaxy that's the heart races I love
both of those movies damn I'm going to
have to go with Captain America to
Mission Impossible 2 or Mission
Impossible rogue nation they said it
possible - okay men in black or
Independence Day I'm going to
Independence Day on that the matrix are
John wick I don't know the matrix the
matrix is classic now John wick was a
great movie but the matrix
come on you can't really compete with
nature you thought to say makers want to
get makes it too or something you can't
put to make this I'll get John with
matrix 1 and matrix to the matrix one
too fast too serious or the fate of the
fear is the fate of the period and I'll
tell you why it's because for some odd
reason we keep getting better every
single time we do a movie so since last
year's were good but where right now is
even better I agree with you it does
keep getting better every time why and
how is this happening I could say so
many things but to try to sum it all up
it's such a great team effort everybody
from the characters to the writer
director producers everyone does their
job to a tee and it's all we keep the
integrity but we always take it to a
whole nother level
and we listen to what the fans want
there you have it there you have it
[Music]
you
[Music]